on just the first day of that so-called
Davos in the desert conference Saudi
Arabia signal deals worth roughly fifty
billion dollars that includes about
thirty five billion of investments in
the Saudi owned oil company Aramco some
of that comes from us-based
oil services companies like Baker Hughes
Halliburton and Schlumberger the
prominent business leaders who have
dropped out include virgin group founder
Richard Branson Ford executive chairman
Bill Ford and JP Morgan CEO Jamie Dimon
treasurer secretary Steve Newton also
decided not to attend but he did appear
on Saudi state TV with the Crown Prince
on Monday resident Trump continues to
insist the massive caravan of migrants
from Central America could include
Middle Eastern terrorists but in
comments yesterday he admitted there is
no proof of that
this morning the crowd is in the mexican
town of weak [ __ ]
it's nearly eleven hundred miles from
the US border about the same mileage as
the distance between New York and
Orlando Florida Adriana Diaz is with the
migrants learning what they hope to
accomplish today Adriana good morning
good morning the migrants are already on
the move this morning and they have a
ten hour trek ahead of them now they're
walking right now on a highway and we
have our lights out but if the lights
weren't here it is pitch-black out here
they are moving at roughly a pace of 25
miles a day and at that pace they're not
going to reach the US border until at
least mid-december now the young men in
this group of course will be able to
move faster than the women with children
so this group is expected to splinter in
the coming weeks
Adriana what's gonna happen in
mid-december when 7,000 people arrive at
the US border well the Trump
administration hasn't announced how it's
going to deal with all of these people
at the border but very few will be able
to actually be granted asylum because
fleeing poverty isn't a qualifying
condition for asylum so these people
don't know what they're expecting but
they feel that there will be some kind
of divine intervention some people have
told us that will allow them to reach
the u.s. even though they are well aware
that the president and the
administration doesn't want them
entering an Adriana Howe
fascinated by how they start and stop
who's organizing these 7,000 people and
how do they know when to stop and start
again
well the caravan started out organized
by grassroots organizations in Honduras
Guatemala Mexico and they these are
migrants themselves these are people who
have told us they are not being paid
they are migrants that also want to get
to the u.s. one is webelo sinfronteras
which is people Without Borders and they
are in this group they're spread out and
they communicate with each other these
organizations they make decisions
amongst the leadership and they
distribute that information via
loudspeakers that we've seen is we're
saying tomorrow you know we're going to
leave at 5 a.m. in the morning so that's
how the information is getting out and
that's how this is being organized right
Adriana Diaz for us in weeks let thanks
so much Adriana